we have two bank accounts in life we  have an emotional bank account we have a  financial backup most of you have been  taught about the financial bank account  that you need to use to get into deals  you need need to have emotional  background you got to man up you got to  have a pair  okay in the military they say send sound  up like you had a pair pina  okay and uh that resonated with me yeah  because i used to have a a squeaky voice  don't have that anymore and my wife says  because i've been yelling for 45 years  maybe that's why i don't have a squeaky  voice anymore um but it's all there but  the kids  but we don't tell the kids that there's  a secret sauce we don't tell them that  there's a shortcut when you tell the  average kid that has never sold anything  your 2 000 cold calls away from being a  multi-millionaire  i guess i don't want to do that that bad  [Music]  do i have to work on the weekends